if you had to battle horrifying demon
Spirits what would you do you'll need to
recruit five deadly ghosts by watching
innocent children die killing innocent
victims and going head-to-head with a
psychotic sexy lady of the night in
order to save your friends and murder
this demon god I'm going to break down
the mistakes made what you should do and
how to beat the five graduate Spirits in
dark Gathering these kids will be forced
to save the world Koro can sense
powerful spirits and is teamed up with
these two expert Ghost Hunter yayoi who
can see spirits with her magic eyes and
her guardian AO they go around town
trapping ghosts in these protection
dolls each time a Ghost Attacks them
their dolls take the damage instead on
the way to stop The Deadly Ghost that
killed yayoi's family Kubo they become
friends with this sweet girl a but have
just discovered that she has been Marked
for Death by something stronger than a
ghost this real life God suddenly
appearing right in yayoi's house this
god of death tells them they've got in
the way of his plans and now he must
kill them but he wants to give them a
fair fight it must come for him with
everything they've got soon or else
he'll kill I here and make her his
Undead wife and disappears before they
have a chance to react but that's when
yayoi's spear dolls start violently
shaking yoi tells her group to leave the
room now rushing out and closing the
door they hear horrifying screams and
Roars coming from inside opening it up
after it's a blood bath all the dolls
have now been brutally killed except for
one this Spirit known as a graduate
yayoi mentions Spirits kill each other
to strengthen their own powers and this
one is just gain the powers of all 40
ghosts in here this is what they'll need
to save AI from the god and the spirit
that killed yayo's family they will need
to recruit five more terrifying
graduates she already has two and add
them to their army in order to do this
what's up guys do you love board games
but does the hustle and bustle of daily
life keep you from actually sitting down
and playing miss those nights sitting
around the Monopoly board hoping that
your little brother will land on
Boardwalk with four hotels well let me
tell you about today's sponsor
introducing Monopoly Go the game that
makes life living as a billionaire as
simple as rolling a die and maybe
flipping a few virtual properties
picture this no more board flips of
missing pieces Monopoly go is like the
classic game you love but with fresh
modded gameplay quick 5 to 15minute
matches reimagined visuals iconic
characters and more Monopoly go is
bringing Classic Fun to the modern era
experience a new way to play Monopoly
with visuals tailored to your phone
collect property build houses and hotels
and earn Monopoly money with gameplay
fit for the botom age with new
opportunities every day participate in
tournaments the prize drop Plinko mini
game cash grab and stay updated with
hourly events for exciting rewards so
what are you waiting for ditch the ramen
noodles and grab your virtual monocle
it's time to rule the Monopoly gold
World install the game now using my link
or scan the QR code on screen and
Unleash Your in a tycoon remember
fortune favors the bold and those who
click the link in the description
remember the path to riches is paved
with virtual dice rolls and strategic
property purchases so download Monopoly
go today and let the Tycoon and you run
wild and don't forget to use my link or
QR code it's How We rise to the top
together now go forth build your Empires
and crush your
opponents thanks for Monopoly go for
sponsoring this video now back to the
show the next day I tells them that she
doesn't remember anything from last
night but she needs to go to her
brother's funeral since he just died
unable to stop her they let her go but
they think of their next plan of attack
because they have another problem last
night all of yayoi's protection dolls
have been destroyed and now they have no
protection if a spirit tries to harm
them let alone a god they need to
capture the god targeting their friend
and will use its power to go after the
ghost that took yayo's family with the
stakes high they lay out their new game
plan that will take them on four Epic
Adventures to achieve their goals one
capture more Spirits for protection two
save a from dying three capture the god
targeting a and for take on yayo's
parents killer Kubo sounds easy and
yayoi has mapped out all the haunted
spots in Tokyo where they'll be able to
find the most terrifying graduation
spirits to prepare their army in the
morning cuz AO tells them that she needs
to leave for work kro plans to go home
but yayoi wants to hang for a bit going
for a bike ride and she tricks him into
going to hunt for their first graduation
Spirit right now and the one they chose
was the soul of thousand selfs slitted
little ones of Kong nearing the
dangerous location kro finally realizes
what's going on but it's too late
they're already there a famous area that
has mysteriously killed many people over
the years Yayo quickly warns him about
what they're about to face and once they
enter this Forest the spirit will never
let them go and they'll be hit with a
deadly curse that has no range limit and
that's when this old woman appears she
tells them she's the tour guide of this
area I will take them to the famous kill
site entering deeper into the force cuz
we' love to do that yayoi can feel
something evil growing stronger around
them but she thinks the spirit around
here isn't evil just angry she hands kro
his protection doll and readies up her
handheld weapon containing the spirit
getting dark yoi tells Koro that she
can't see spirits in bad lighting so he
must tell at the moment he senses
something wrong they continue walking
but yayoi suddenly gets grabbed by kro
it's weird not realizing she's being
tricked by this woman who is actually an
evil spirit yayoi collapses on the floor
unconscious and helpless about to
consume her soul the old Spirit notices
something strange on yayoi's finger not
realizing it's her greatest weapon
meanwhile the real katol gets split up
and now now all alone and he figures out
the evil spirit must be playing tricks
and he his footsteps approaching him he
freaks out and runs to find yayoi but
suddenly a vision hits him forcing him
to see how this place became so evil
seeing village women running for their
lives from Evil soldiers to prevent
themselves from getting tortured they
stabbed and stabbed and fell down this
waterfall shocking him back awake but
finds blood on his hands realizing his
protection doll has just saved his life
but it won't help him for much longer
rushing off he finds yayoi dead evil
spirits quickly surround him and he
knows this is the end throwing up Hill
Mary kro double checks yayo's vitals but
that's when she grabs him showing this
isn't yayoi but actually a demon and he
starts dragging him up into the sky with
the other victims about to die the real
yayoi returns last minute and stabs the
spirit with her finger weapon and saves
kataro revealing that her weapon saved
her last minute against the old Spirit
lady earlier but it ain't over still
trapped within the spirit Dome this
graduate Spirit eats the creatures and
captures around it and they can only
Escape if they kill or capture it okay
if I was them I would have prepared by
focusing on strength their Team Dynamics
cuz even if kro was bait there was no
excuse let me explain kro was nowhere
near mentally prepared for this
situation even though they had enough
online info about this ghost from
beforehand which means last minute
planning for this mission was a huge
mistake I can't believe he allowed this
little girl to take him to this place
well yeah kro can sense Spirits without
using his eyes yayoi can only see
spirits with her eyes and even if this
Mission could only take place at night I
would have cheated the system by waiting
to begin this Mission the moment Sundown
began this would have at least given us
about 70 minutes to hunt before darkness
which would have provided us with better
visual Clarity and allow yoyoi to be at
her full power level to be at her best
and also why didn't they read a few
books beforehand because if you know the
gruesome history of the area in advance
it means that there was no guarantee
that krool would not have broken down
last minute from seeing all of this
gruesomeness especially since he is
naturally sensitive and because of this
I would have brought along AO since she
would not have been supernaturally
sensitive and could have come in handy
helping krol focus in case something as
traumatizing as this potentially threw
him off you see what I mean because this
would have helped him keep more centered
and focused during these critical
moments especially if he was a big part
of yayoi's plan with no moves left yayoi
takes out her first graduate from
earlier mourn high priest of evil Sutra
and then she hands kro some noise
cancelling headphones warning him to not
listen to the priest no matter what
happens and this graduate starts
speaking his death Mantra causing all
living things that hear him to die
instantly trapping everything around him
this woman swiftly cuts off yayoi's
graduate head but he doesn't stop
forcing her to run away and she tries to
surprise attack him but yoy directs kro
to quickly track it down cornering it
they quickly catch her and thinks it's
over but then she notices a strange Aura
coming from nearby and they track it to
this Old Death Grudge seal boox and find
a dried up mummified hand and suddenly
the evil spirit starts freaking out and
losing control and yayoi quickly cuts
off her connection to the hand and turns
her back into a normal Spirit too
strange to be a coincidence they think
this hand was planted here on purpose to
make this Spirit evil but they don't
know why so they decide to save
safeguarded and This Woman's Spirit
thanks her for saving her and yayoi
offers her two choices she can either
die right here or fight as her prisoner
liking Yayo the spirit agrees to fight
for her anytime woohoo great that's one
graduate down and four more to go
heading back home AKO gets mad that they
went on a mission without her but they
agree to bring her on the next one so
chill out yeah yoi stores the mummified
hand summer safely it's so gross and
they get ready to hit up the next
graduate but yayoi tells them she has
other plans and wants to pick up another
graduate that she's already captured kro
thinks they'll finally catch a break but
she tells him he's dead wrong too deadly
to keep it home yoi stores this graduate
far away from humans in a secret
location and brings it out only on the
deadliest of missions and so she gives
them the rundown they must secure The
Graduate soul of a Fearless Japanese
soldier with an insane healing ability
killing hundreds of enemies in his past
life their souls cling on to him now due
to his healing power he can't pass on
but yayoi made a deal to help him die
one day if he helped her on a few
missions first arriving at the location
they spot B this mannequin The Graduate
is resting inside of its head and then
this TV turns on spotting dozens of
ghost soldiers coming towards them yoi
tells them her graduate is warning them
to be careful because he can't stop his
enemies from harming them this Spirit
rushes for kataro forcing him to drink
his water preventing the spirit from
killing thinking he's safe woo his
stomach starts feeling weird lifting up
his shirt he sees bite marks but they
aren't harming him his protection doll's
stomach then bursts open making him
realize the spirits are trying to drink
the moisture in his blood his protection
doll suddenly explodes and now he has no
protection okay well looked I know this
situation seems hopeless but I would
have be in the situation by using a
couple of water guns and some homemade
torches let me explain listen what we
know about this demon Sergeant ghost guy
is he was some kind of dude who was
constantly tortured by the souls he
killed during war time and just like the
sergeant the soldiers around him aren't
evil but because of their Soldier
instincts they won't hesitate to kill us
out of cold Instinct this makes these
ghosts more dangerous than regular spe
since for these guys killing us is like
rushing their teeth unlike others that
kill from a deep emotional state the
spirits around the demon Sergeant guy
have been feeding on him this whole time
which means the seal keeping him inside
the protection doll isn't as strong and
that's why all of this scary [__] is
still leaking out into the outside world
so in order to capture him again safely
we need to reseal him as quickly as
possible so to do this I would use a
classic military Blitz Greek tactic used
to create shock and disorganization in
enemy forces by using the elements of
speed surprise and superiority and
Firepower I know you're skeptical about
the water guns but bear with me so in
order to pull this off we also need to
be able to see the spirits rub against
and we know they rely on water in order
to distract them so to accomplish our
mission I'm going to first stock up on
some drinkable water bags that could
hold up to 3 l and not just a few
pathetic Supermarket water bottles that
are tiny and I'm also going to hit the
local toy store or a Dollar General or
whatever the equivalent is over there
and buy some water guns so that we can
effectively spray water long distances
and distract the Thirsty ghosts even
more heading to the location instead of
getting there by foot I would have tried
to drive straight to the haunted
location by going through the Gap at the
spot they parked at which would have
allowed us to light up the entire area
with our car headlights if that wasn't
possible I would have also brought along
a few strong torches and Advance the
point is by focusing on the major
factors of this Mission they could have
streamlined this process way more AO
rushes to The Graduate doll to tighten
its seal hoping this will seal off the
evil spirits around them as well
grabbing it she throws water near her to
distract the Thirsty spirits and throw
the doll to these two kro ties the
spirit rope Around The Graduate even
more tightly sealing it him and his
[__] for good that's two graduates
down and now three more to go and now
kro thinks that maybe they can just
relax a little bit but no yayoi reminds
him that this graduate was already
captured and unlike the last two the
next one will not be in Chained and is
not helpful and is pure evil reaching
the next spot kro senses the correct
tunnel they should go into and just as
they spot a protection doll under the
seat yayoi tells them this Spirit has a
habit for running away and must have
avoided getting killed in a room earlier
kro carries it for Extra Protection and
they approach the Kill Zone reading info
about this haunted area online they find
out that a family was killed by an Axe
Murderer near here years ago and dozens
of ghosts in this tunnel are suspected
to be his victims and if they spot a
mirror that doesn't belong here in front
of them then that means something horri
Ying will happen to them just as they
spot this mirror holy [__] but they
don't know if it belongs here or not so
they're freaking out AO looks online to
compare pics but her phone starts
glitching [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] yayoi
spots something strange happened to AO
and they all go in meanwhile kro walks
with yayoi but senses something stange
realizing AO here is actually a ghost
and the real one must have gotten
Spirited Away and then she finds out
that she lost connection before they
went in the tunnel seconds ago they
decide to play it cool and let the
spirit guide them back to AO and
suddenly K's protection go gets sliced
off and he senses AO is right above them
in another realm this Spirit attacks
yayoi telling her the full story of what
happened here when she was alive she
tried to save her friend from the axe
killer but her friend wanted her to die
as well and now everyone must die
because of her yoi captures it and asks
for them to lead them to her and AO just
as they reach AO they see that the axe
ghost is wearing her protection ghost
face it drags her inside the tunnel and
tells them to follow him if they want to
rescue her knowing this ghost has the
upper hand in tight areas and they can't
unleash their graduate Spirits in here
yoi lays out the new game plan grab AO
and Escape because it's too tight to
fight inclosed areas they got to get
this thing outside if they want to win
they head in and kro sees his protection
doll's eyes being crushed spotting one
of the ax ghost victims its eyes are
missing and this Ghost says it wants to
play a game of tag with them yoi warns
kro they'll end up like this victim if
they get caught okay while the odds of
this Mission might seem against us I
would have relied on Japan's growing
population of extreme shans in order to
take on this ghost here's how the ghost
is a psycho killer and extreme sist who
enjoys hunting down its prey slowly
before killing them I would have pled
better counter defenses against what we
already knew could have happened since
again we had information about this
ghost heading in yoi was the only one
properly prepared I would have focused
on everyone sticking as close to her as
possible especially since we knew the
killer likeed to isolate his victims
through manipulation meaning not getting
separated was our main defense duh
however given this ghost speed and
overwhelming Terror and since we can't
unleash our graduate in this tight area
which is so annoying I would focus more
on luring him outside of the tunnel in
order to fight him using ruthless
tactics like relying on on something
known hiiki kamori this is a word in
Japan that is used to describe someone
who socially withdraws from society for
at least 6 months and this is a problem
over there and some don't even leave
their bedrooms and are full- on
shuttings finding such people would make
the perfect bait for us to use against
the ghost since no one would notice
their disappearance for months or even
years anyways no one would care we then
could have lured out the evil spirit
more effectively also I would have kept
all three of us on a single line tether
robe in order to minimize our risks of
getting separated during the mission
it's amazing how they don't think of
this stuff taking acho they for the exit
but pass more sick [__] the protection
dolls takes more hits and yayoi warns
them that they can't lose any more dolls
or Els getting out they now have the
upper hand and now can unleash their
graduate demon Sergeant anything in this
area will get affected by its powers it
easily grabs the axe murder and rips it
apart causing it to suffer the same way
he did in the war making it thin
starvation meanwhile yayoi puts down a
camera so they can watch the battle
while they get some distance away from
their graduates danger range meanwhile
the demon Sergeant begs Axe Murder to
kill him but he's too overpowered it
tells him that he did well takes out a
grenade and initiates the final stage of
his powers blowing up everything within
range not far enough from the danger Kat
throws yayoi out of the blast range but
his legs get caught in the spell causing
him to instantly lose weight and feel
weak yayoi tells him since only his feet
were affected he should be fine in a few
days yeah hope seeing her graduate win
the battle they head back yayoi tells
kro that she will use whatever Spirit
good or evil to save her family and
finally captures the Axe Murder a ghost
that's three graduates down and two more
to go yeah you heads back inside the
tunnel to collect more evil spirits to
use for her Army which she has over 30
now by the way heading back to the car
an evil spirit sneaks in and tries to
surprise attack AO but yoi captures it
and leaves her fate to AO heading home
AO works on creating a new type of
protection doll one that will be able to
take infinite damage using the spear
they just tried to kill her ah that is
so fitting later she tells yayoi that
she knows where to store the powerful
mummified hand they had found because
it's too dangerous to keep it home so
what does she do she proposes they
should buy a whole booty of a second
house and store all the graduates it and
mummified hand away from the public
where it'll be safe cuz that's super
practical and somehow he agrees and then
they go off on another crazy haunted
house hunting Adventure getting a new
place to store all of their graduates
while kro gains his strength back from
the demon Sergeant spell after that yoi
says they need two more graduates to
finish their army once in the wild and
one Yayo is already captured well sort
of and then they head off for their
Deadliest Mission yet the evil cortison
reaching this abandoned love Hotel this
place was owned by the Yakuza and they
brought back girls here to toy with and
kill them desperate for a way out in the
afterlife these girl Spirits imagine a
secret room in the hotel for them to
escape to and this is where yayoi hit
her evil cortison graduate in the
bathroom great place but uh there's a
problem each time she tried to retrieve
her yayoi ends up at the entrance of the
hotel and thinks The Graduate is behind
this she won't let anyone go in there
and hates all women staring at K they
robe him in to lead to the mission and
he prepares to be seduced memorizing the
location of the secret room they arm him
with two graduates to bring with him H
Castle ruin Spirit and the demon
Sergeant heading in KRA appears in a
different away from Yayo and eeko and
thinks this cortison is on to them
sneaking in he manages to avoid the
wandering ghosts and moves like a ninja
and nears the main room and suddenly
this ghost shows up and grabs him and
they switch entire bodies horrified he
switches back into his own body and runs
straight for the room entering he spots
AO shocked he rushes to try and free her
but she starts taking off her clothes
and tells him she'll reward him if she
gets free oo and that's when K's neck
gets stabbed realizing his protection
doll has saved him realizing that AKO is
actually The Graduate setting the room
on fire she warns him to let her free if
he wants to escape about to die he takes
out his protection doll to stay alive
meanwhile Yayo and acho try to find kro
hearing his voice and come into the same
room but they don't see him okay the
goal here is to capture this graduate so
our best bet is to not get caught doing
it and this is why I would first entered
and not acted like a dumbass for
starters it's obvious that the ghost
here was a professional night walker in
her past life and now has powers
therefore it is safe to say that she
would have tried to play some evil
tricks on us the moment we walked in
including pretending to be AO here when
we clearly knew ago did not come with us
at all instead of letting her fool us
and letting her lead us into an obvious
trap I would have entered this room and
gone Balls to the walls instead by using
our greatest trap card in the history
that no ghost could handle our fresh
virginity so here's what we're going to
do we're going to come in straight and
just tell her right on and that would
have done two things it would have
caught the ghost off guard for starters
because she'd be like what the freak he
doesn't seem scared and he's a virgin
and this would have given us more time
to get closer to her physically and
allow us to tire up at close range she
was already super excited that a man was
entering but telling her we were a big
bad virgin could have been Next Level
which she would have been able to verify
since she could have likely smelled it
off of us this would have caught her off
guard and would have allowed us to keep
her distracted till we got close enough
to sear her doll up before she could do
anything AO puts out her hand and calls
out him and her Love Somehow reaches kro
through Dimensions distracts The Ghost
and allows Kato to safely recapture The
Graduate I don't know don't question it
move on be happy they finally managed to
retrieve yayoi's graduate and now that's
four down and one more to go and then
they head off to capture the next Wild
ghost on this list the black oera of the
eclipse reaching there they spot someone
else already there najo shami
recognizing her from TV she's a famous
spiritualist and they're like holy [__]
yayoi gets super excited to see somebody
like her not realizing this woman is
being possessed but kro cons sends she's
a little suspicious but doesn't know why
najo warns them this place is dangerous
and they should follow her heading to
the Water Bridge Kor spots this boy
sitting and hands him his drawing book
telling him that he lives with his dad
cuz his mother's gone but something is
off this kid Reveals His evil stepmother
cheated on his dad dad with another guy
and then killed his dad and the guy she
was dating turning their bodies into
meatballs which the kid accidentally ate
just as the stepmother killed him too
snapping out of the illusion the boy
appears on the Water Bridge in the
distance and lets out a horrifying
scream and they realize this kid is
their target he declares his mother will
pay this Spirit appears behind kro but
najo saves him getting her arm cut off
and gets dragged up the wall to die
looking through the kid drawing a second
time he realizes this ghost thinks
everyone he sees looks like his
horrifying stepmother and is on a quest
to kill them all the ghost breaks najo
apart and and turns her into human
meatballs but that's when she turns into
a full-on spirit and Kor realizes that
she must been possessed this whole time
and the real najo is already dead yayoi
tells them this ghost power He will draw
you and blot a part of your body out in
a Sketchbook basically decapitating your
body and will turn you into meatballs
for him to eat cuz he's a cannibal and
full of pure hatred and look they're
good as long as they have their
protection dolls but their protection
isn't going to last much longer and they
got to Target the ghost's greatest
Weapon It's notebook okay yeah well this
kid seems too powerful we could have won
this thing by using our most useless
graduate for this job and way this kid
would have never expected look this
group so far is only thinking of optimal
conditions to release the perfect
graduate for each evil ghost day they
fight what they aren't considering is
using them as a simple distraction as
well because that's how you'll win and
look since they have all the graduates
on them I would have also brought along
better equipment to counter against any
Friendly Fire we'd encounter from the
graduates we'd unleash and in this case
I would have whipped out the evil high
priest of Sutra from earlier and put on
some earplugs duh he long slow range
attacks might not have worked to put
down this kid but deploying him anyways
for him to take on the kid that's
something else entirely it means that we
would have been able to keep our enemy
distracted enough for us to sneak up
close and steal his two biggest
weaknesses the notebook and his
meatballs unlike the other Spirits this
kid relies on external weapons and
accessories to function at his best in
reality all you needed to do was to just
throw at them all three of your graduate
Spirits it's not that hard people
suddenly yayoi gets cut and pulled up to
die dropping her protection doll kro
gets pulled down by the spirit's hands
Water Rising and tries to drown him and
tells AO to save yayoi before it's too
late picking up the protection doll she
rushes to her just as the doll gets
ripped apart but it's still intact
realizing her newly improved protection
doll she made earlier which is made of
rubber is still protecting her helping
yayoi and handing her weapon and
protection doll back they barely make it
back to kro in the chaos yayoi Cuts this
spirit's arm with her weapon while aeko
knocks the evil spirit back dropping his
notebook into the water destroying its
greatest weapon pissing it off and tries
to go for yayoi but she blocks the
attack with her doll and that was this
boy's biggest mistake yayoi reveals
because this boy harmed her psychotic
cortison there's less chance she'll harm
them and will focus on killing the boy
allowing them to release this psycho
cortison uriri Beautiful Soul slurper
the boy Spirit turns part of their
graduates flesh into meatballs consuming
it but that's when she lets out a bunch
of lethal butterflies touching the boy
it sucks his soul and activates her
second diseased curse training the boy's
youth to make her more beautiful making
him freak out as the last measure of
attack it attacks one final time and
that's when yayoi throws an old mirror
towards the graduate showing her hideous
face and reveals her true ugly side erup
into a grudge of fire and that defeats
the boy but that's when it turns back to
yayo's group and they realize it's about
to kill them active fast they rush to TI
The Graduate seal in order to stop it
kro takes out another graduate to
counter but that's when yayoi realizes
the G graduate needs its eyes to lock
onto his Target telling their other
graduate to aim for her weakness
temporarily blinding her kro sneaks up
behind her and closes off her graduate
seal for good and after that they
capture the boy's Spirit finally they
got all five of them plus the two they
already have with their army complete
they get ready to take on their most
dangerous enemy about to leave the they
spot naj's bag Left Behind opening it
they see another mummified hand the same
type that drove one of their graduates
mad earlier wondering why she has it yet
yoi thinks they're secretly creating
more evil spirits in the world on
purpose after they called the police and
informed them of what happened leaving
out certain details later on they run
into nao's twin sister at the station
namiko and she thinks what Yayo is
suspecting too that her sister was
killed and replaced by Spirit warning
them that many spiritualists have been
getting replaced recently they think
something is going on and so they swap
business cards and agree to talk more
later a few days later kro and the team
Count Their graduates and realize their
army is nearly ready but that's when
they see their friend I on the news
she's been caught in a train accident
and they spot their mortal enemies on TV
the spirit who took yayoi's parents Kubo
and the God trying to marry AI yayoi
says AI should be safe for now since the
God isn't planning to kill her just yet
and shouldn't be harmed by Kubo either
wanting to go investigate A's home and
KIU to get some answers on what's going
on Ako and kro remind yayoi that
tomorrow she starts school again
annoying her that she has to deal with
kid [__] again the next day she
heads to school hoping I is okay and
tries to figure out a wave to shut down
her school but meets this strange girl
Dorothy fste saying she's from the class
next door and says she knows yayoi can
see spirits because she could see them
too and basically convinces to help her
stop some Spirits in school roping her
non-believer classmates into the hunt
but last minute reveals that she's been
trying to create a super evil spirit and
leads them into a trap and force them to
go through horrifying nightmare that
yayoi barely survives herself and her
classmates but no one can remember
anything so the school is shut down
until further notice the end Dorothy
meets up with the aoi after and
congratulates her on solving another
mystery but reveals a shocking twist her
and her friend are behind the train
accident on the news and have been
raising a powerful Spirit named Kubo
this entire time in plans to use him to
destroy the world not realizing that yoi
knows who Kubo is yayoi wonders how this
girl is connected to her family but
keeps quiet Dorothy shut down the school
because she has bigger plans and reveals
she's been replaced and wanted to see
yayo's powers in action in order to
recruit her to the team yayoi thinks
quick and makes up a story that she has
also been replaced but doesn't know much
about this body she is in both onto each
other but curious to find out more they
create a hang out later while yayoi
tries to find out everything from the
spirit that took cook her family linking
up with AO yayoi also updates her new
ally namiko telling her she has just met
someone who has also been replaced and
thinks she might be connected with their
sister's replacement but worries Dorothy
might know about their family so they
will go hide out in A's Hometown Kyoto
but will put hidden cameras in their
house here to monitor namiko offers to
protect yayo's people while yayoi keeps
her updated on the Dorothy situation and
agree to both work to take down namiko's
sister killer and figure out how to stop
yayo's mortal enemies preparing to head
back to Kyoto to rescue Ai and with
seven graduates they lay down their
final plan they will spread out all the
graduates around Kyoto to create a curse
on the whole city weakening the enemy
and overpowering it the gang creates new
tech AO with her special infinite
repairing doll and K's graduate
deployment set for the mission and yoi
says she'll hide the mysterious enemy's
right mummified arm in their storage
house and will place a tracker on it in
case they try to find it not knowing
what it's for they bring the left
mummified arm of theirs to Kyoto just in
case and the group heads back up and
head to rescue AI but what do you think
about the video don't forget to like
subscribe and leave a comment down below
and as always don't forget to check out
our how to be playlist